que stéphanie gibeau auteur du livre la
traque des lanceurs d'alert aux éditions
max milo et stéphanie gibeau merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors le
report des audiences concernant
l'extradition d'assange suffira-t-il à
ses avocats pour préparer la défense de
leurs clients
témoin ce que je comprends c'est qu'en
fait des audiences commencerait à partir
du 1er mai où d'élu mais c'est sain et
que et que le procès après aurelio à
l'automne donc écouter j'espère le tout
est de savoir comment comment il va lui
puisqu'on a appris qu'il y avait eu des
détenus qui étaient les sauces succomber
du coronavirus ce que je comprends aussi
c'est que la prison de bell marchés et
un petit peu sens dessus dessous parce
qu'il ya du personnel qui qui peut plus
ni travail et donc de tous serait quand
même de savoir comment lui vint et
comment les choses sans pouvoir avancer
oui alors wikileaks avait récemment
déposé une plainte à l'encontre d'une
entreprise espagnole elle aurait
espionné julian assange et sa famille
pour le compte du gouvernement américain
est ce qu'on peut craindre des
tentatives de déstabilisation avant
l'audience et si oui dans quel but
le style julian assange est un dossier
éminemment politique
on ne le sait que trop est justement sa
situation fait que c'est le seul
prisonnier politique en europe donc les
déstabilisations wii sont à attendre de
toutes parts alors seul prisonnier
politique en europe vous le dites est ce
qu'on peut s'attendre dans ces
conditions encore à l'intervention d'un
gouvernement étranger qui pourrait lui
venir en aide
tg justement publié une tribune en fin
de semaine dernière concernant notre
pays qui sont la scène internationale
comme vous le savez est pénible la
déclaration des droits de l'homme qui
est reconnu par rapport à son humanisme
qui a toujours accueilli justement des
prisonniers politiques des gens qui
étaient persécutés et dans le dossier de
lunas ans qui est fabuleuse
il a publié des informations qui ont
aidé à comprendre que nous la france et
qui ont en danger puisque ont été
écoutés par une puissance étrangère
donc la france a montré a brillé par son
absence depuis 2000 12 2008 2012
on a toujours rien entendu de la part de
nos élus de premier plan et nous on
l'expliqué justement ce silence cette
indifférence de la france à l'égard de
la situation julian assange
mais je peux aussi vous posez la
question de pourquoi la france est
incapable de protéger ses lanceurs
d'alert pourquoi la france est incapable
de lutter contre la fraude fiscale alors
qu'elle ne dit elle dit le faire c'est à
dire qu'il ya des paroles d'un côté et
des actes de l'autre il ya beaucoup
d'hypocrisie beaucoup de mensonges
beaucoup de manipulations et des
intérêts de certains intérêts personnels
à ce que justement des gens honnêtes
perdre tout pour que leur petite affaire
perdure c'est c'est très dommageable
pour notre pays
alors pour conclure il ya eu ces
récentes révélations sur la vie privée
de julien assange notamment au sujet de
sa compagne et de ses enfants
est ce que ces révélations peuvent jouer
en la faveur de julian assange
mais ce qui est complètement incroyable
si vous voulez c'est que l'un on
aimerait entendre la parole par exemple
des associations des droits de l'enfant
des associations des droits de l'homme
des associations qui militent justement
pour pour la famille enfin on se on se
demande où en sont nos démocraties
puisqu'a priori la grande bretagne se
revendique est une démocratie
enfin je crois que c'est ça qui est
stupéfiant c'est le silence de toutes
les autorités
quelle qu'elle soit qui
laisse une salle est si vous voulez un
goût vraiment amer parce qu'on est en
train de se rencontrent là en 2020 que
toutes ces paroles n'ont absolument rien
à voir avec les actes qui nous l état en
fait la question c'est ça où est l'état
merci beaucoup stephanie giroux d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes et auteur du livre la traque
des lanceurs dallaire aux éditions max
milo
merci merci à vous